foreign
I wanted to call attention to something
interesting that happened in the
Atlantic which is increasingly taking
over as the main source of nonsense for
uh left-leaning Elites
um
uh given the New York Times a run for
its money the New York Times has kind of
spent you know people have caught on to
the fact that it doesn't make a whole
heck of a lot of sense but yeah I know
we've talked about the Atlantic a lot
during covid and there are three writers
that they've got in um
doing we're doing a lot of writing about
coven I don't I'm not sure they got
anything right no no they didn't I mean
you know nobody's perfect but they they
made a pretty good show yeah they had a
perfectly wrong showing perfectly wrong
showing and they are you know they are
definitely uh heralded the whole the
whole magazine is in the sort of you
know 25 a bottle and up cocktail party
realm you know you're talking about
bottles of booze or bottles wine yeah
why yeah no no no the Boost is way
fancier than that yeah um but anyway so
I want to just show exactly yeah no I
but I will say before you do that that
um and I've said this before
but the Atlantic and Harpers are
standbys we we still subscribe we still
get the hard copies uh and I have I have
loved these magazines
I they have been uh the sort of The
Shining the beacons on the hill of great
writing and fantastic reporting and
the Atlantic Has Fallen
yeah
that's one standby that I will not stand
by and increasingly won't even stand for
you know what I'm saying I do yeah it's
it's broken and here we can show you um
yeah sure let's show the original so the
uh the the Atlantic said the quiet part
out loud in the title to this article
now of course titles are not produced by
the authors of the article generally but
nonetheless the Atlantic proclaims in
the title to this article from I believe
yesterday
covid shots are still one giant
experiment
[Music]
right oops one giant experiment huh I
wonder if there are any let's say codes
that would cover the application of an
experiment to oh I don't know let's say
Humanity right gee the Nuremberg code
might be one and oh my God if the
Nuremberg code applies to these shots do
you know what we were entitled to
you're not going to believe this unless
you remember the beginning of the
episode where we talked about informed
consent right we would have been do
informed consent in the event that we
were exposed to an experiment which we
apparently clearly were as far as the
people who titled that piece in the
Atlantic is so all right let's say maybe
maybe that was just one editor who was
off their meds who titled the thing and
the rest does not reflect an experiment
right and so that would explain why the
Atlantic then swapped out quickly
without saying anything the title yeah
within a day they swapped it out so I
got this from the uh the way back
machine now let's see what what is the
article currently titled Zach that's it
oh
balls covered shots may be different in
one key way well that doesn't say
experiment at all huh it's got the same
subtitle it's the same article it's the
same article the article is in fact
unchanged now scroll down to the
paragraph where there's a paragraph in
there see if I can find it that says
that it does not use the term experiment
but what it does is it in some very
mealy-mouthed way
says that the covid shots are
effectively a big beta test which is a
synonym for experiment right that is a
not ready for prime time you got it at
the same time coveted vaccines are still
a sort of beta at a sort of beta testing
stage interesting
are still in a sort of beta testing
stage they don't even want to say it
flat out but the point is
the original title of the article that
sentence the history of what has gone on
in the Atlantic makes it very clear that
they know that they are dealing with an
experiment and therefore ought to know
that Nuremberg applies and even if they
don't understand what Nuremberg is or
where informed consent is every these
are well-educated people these are
people who went to fine schools and
benefited from all that comes from that
they ought to know and what I'm
wondering when a
when a recognition like this
circulates through the offices of the
Atlantic or whatever happens on their
email list or however it is these people
gather
how is it that all of these people who
presumably took these shots themselves
nobody in that Community says hey wait a
minute nobody told me it was an
experiment in fact I remember very
distinctly they told me it was safe and
effective they specifically put out
animations that told me that although
the process had been accelerated every
single step was done and that they knew
these things to be safe and that if I
took them I would not get the disease
and I would not suffer any ill effects
from them they wouldn't kill my
neighbors right
now
nobody says that right there's no
acknowledgment you should have people by
this thousand saying wait a minute
experiment
this was an experiment you you lied to
me you told me it was something other
than an experiment and now you're
telling me after I can undo it you tell
me the experiments had already been done
yeah and the clinical trials were yes
accelerated
but complete
those were lies those those were lies
and the point is they weren't you know
we're not talking about uh
civil liability or even criminal guilt
we are talking about something above
that we are talking about violations of
the Nuremberg code and of the
Hippocratic oath and we are also talking
about violations of our Free Speech
rights in order to obscure all of this
right this is a four alarm fire this is
civilization violating all of its sacred
principles simultaneously and doing so
with human life and limb on the line
right it couldn't be more important and
it is time that we sobered up and we
looked at the violations of our most
sacred principles that we are engaged in
and said who the hell is in charge here
right how are we going to undo this
before it's too late
foreign
[Music]